would you suggest people because
obviously there's people who've been
eating [ __ ] on crypto recently and nfts
and [ __ ] like you're very smart with
your money like how how involved did you
get with the crypto space not very
smart
[Music]
i had a lot of advice and you know i
feel like we took the right ones but i
did do a
some you know to some degree yeah yeah
you dabbled yeah yeah it's not you know
me
turning a lot of money into
non-money yeah a lot of uh
well you know you saw like a lot of
people are like naughty probably not
even to their own knowledge like we're
like a part of ponzi schemes like
artists and like even the dude from the
sacramento kings
uh what scheme like like some of these
nft they call them like rug pools okay
so they they are like uh what's uh
darren fox who signed 185 million dollar
contract for the kings
launched his own nft with a company
and then i guess they sold like when
everyone bought in and then dipped so
they're like there's like it's like
that's yeah that's they're like it's a
lot looking great yeah you know what i'm
saying so that dude's in panama
somewhere chilling well also like you
signed 185 million dollar contract with
the kings bro like yeah yeah no you
can't do that [ __ ] i believe it though
because it's like that's
all that they were going after is like
high quick money and it's also the quick
it's like that quick nutshell that's the
only way to get value that quick is to
go after somebody who's like high value
i mean you know what i mean so it's like
if you have a lighter and it's like it's
not really a lighter until [ __ ] like
lebron
on the logo lebron touched it then it's
like oh yeah now we got these i got
lebron's lighter yeah it's like it's
cooler now you know what i'm saying so
they were doing that with like nfts and
all of those companies they were just
using artists to like promote them and
bring value to themselves but that [ __ ]
wasn't about nothing